- One of the great things in business is,
you don't know if you don't ask.
And so one of the reasons I
love Twitter, and social media,
and specifically Twitter
is I see the comments more,
even more than on Instagram.
And sometimes jump in
and surprise and delight.
You are witnessing a surprise
and delight right now.
What's the number?
(phone rings)
Crystal, you better pick up.
- [Crystal] Hello?
- Hey Crystal, it's Gary Vee.
- Oh my god, Gary freaking Vaynerchuk.
- How are you?
- [Crystal] I'm doing great.
Thank you, thank you, thank
you so, so much for calling me.
I have been on 10 since
you tweeted me yesterday.
- I love it.
I love living on 10 and
anything I can do to get people
to live on 10 is exactly right.
I like that.
So what can I help you with?
- Okay, I have two things.
One, I'm gonna ask on behalf of me.
I'm 26, I want to be,
I wanna say, a marriage counselor.
I'm not sure if even that's
the right word 'cause
I don't want to be boxed
into an office, a clinic,
or what have you.
I see my future writing books,
doing speaking engagements,
conferences, things like that.
Just so I can point information
and tools so that people
can have better marriages.
But I am finding the
every time I mention that,
let's go, what do you
wanna do with your life,
and I tell people this,
their instant response is,
"How are you gonna do that?
"You're not married."
(Gary chuckles)
My parents are divorced as of I was eight.
I'm not married--
- I can answer your question right away.
- [Crystal] Can you?
- Yeah.
We're gonna build an
amazing case study together.
I'm gonna give you three names
and then you're going to
cruise into the sunset
of success which is,
let's figure out the three
most successful coaches
in the history of sport
that everybody knows of
that didn't play that sport.
Bill Belichick, even though
I hate him with all my guts,
did not play football.
He grew up in the football game.
His dad was a coach, and what have you.
But Bill Belichick did not play football.
And he will probably, unfortunately,
go down as the greatest,
or if not one of the greatest
head coaches of all time.
You don't have to be, listen.
I think people have to be thoughtful.
I hate 22 year old life coaches
that haven't lived life.
But if they speak about,
here's my life experiences and why,
you can eliminate, though, very quickly,
when somebody says to you.
(fumbles over words)
Let me, first of all, a
couple other questions.
Are your friends and your circle
telling you you can't do that?
Or are customers that you're
trying to do that with
telling you that they
don't want to go with you
because you're not married?
- [Crystal] No, this
is more acquaintances,
people that I run into.
- Listen, that's a mistake.
Listen, that's a mistake.
You can't listen to acquaintances.
Their opinions don't matter.
- [Crystal] Okay.
- You can't listen.
- [Crystal] How do I
deal with that without,
I'm sorry.
- No, go ahead, I'm sorry,
I'm getting excited.
You should talk, go.
- [Crystal] So am I!
Basically, I wanna,
because I follow you and
I've been following you
for a couple of years now,
and I do agree what you
have to say about education.
I do think people are gonna start moving
from going to school and
sending their kids to school
to finding ways--
- I've got your answer.
I've got your answer.
A lot of people get--
- [Crystal] You know what I'm gonna ask?
- Of course I know.
I know exactly where you're going.
So if you're not gonna get the PhD,
there's only a few ways to justify,
and gives confidence to the end market,
why they would jump with you.
It's crazy to me that so many people,
I was watching 60 Minutes last night
in the background as I was working,
and the way that Oprah
was justifying the person
was he has a PhD in this
and a master's in that.
Even 60 Minutes used those pieces
of paper to create authority.
In our society, pieces
of paper from businesses,
and that's what colleges
are, has the authority.
The only people that get authority
are the people that have
gone out and done it
and have people co-signing them, right?
Makes sense.
So the way you,
and this is why I love working for free.
When you don't have a piece of paper,
one of the reasons I love working for free
is working for free for somebody
who is that person in society,
whether they've got a piece of paper
or they're Puff Daddy
and they just did it.
Become the equity that you trade under
once you become great at something.
Andy, who's sitting here right now,
had every singe famous person I see
gives him a lot of street cred right away,
not because he got a fucking degree
for personal branding and marketing
from Virginia Tech.
What degree did you get?
- [Andy] Political science.
- Not because of his fucking
bullshit political science
degree from Virginia Tech.
But because he went and
worked underneath me
and I went out and did it,
and I always give him love
and good vibes, the end.
It's not Babin's degree
from the USC school
of fucking film or NYU.
- [Babin] I dropped out, but--
- So what you need to do,
what you need to do is one of two moves
if you're not gonna go get a PhD
and have everybody comfortable with it.
You either need to go work for somebody
that is the authority,
and ask all 1000s of
people that are authorities
and work for them,
or you need to give your services for free
to five couples, crush it for them,
and use their word of
mouth and endorsements
as your leverage point.
The end.
There are three ways to win the game.
One, the traditional piece of paper route,
two, work for free for somebody
and siphon off their equity
once you deliver for them,
or three, eat shit and do
it yourself in the beginning
and let the testimonials
of the early people
give it for you.
I'm three.
I recommend, often, two.
99% of the world plays one.
- [Crystal] Okay,
awesome, awesome, awesome.
- That was good shit, actually.
- [Crystal] That was
good, that was amazing.
- It's very rare when I
get to the real point.
Like, that's the fucking point.
Those are the three pillars of trying
to gain market acceptance.
The three pillars of market acceptance.
- [Crystal] I love it, I love it.
And then, so I cannot wait to message you
in, like, a year or three to five years
and tell you where I'm at.
- Me too.
By the way, I live for that shit.
My whole fucking being is, right now,
is based on that shit.
- [Andy] It would be good content, too.
- It will be great content.
Yeah, that is gonna be great content.
Okay, real quick because I
gotta run through my next thing.
What's the other, you had another thing.
- [Crystal] Yes, so I
work for a company here
(mumbles), Pennsylvania.
We're a wholesaler for memory cards.
And I do work here and I
enjoy what I do for the team,
and they just bring so much
value to me and my life
that I really want to be a
next level employee here.
I want to help them
with their social media,
but I just don't know how to do it,
if what we're doing is non-proprietary.
- You build a brand.
You build a reputation.
When you're not proprietary,
like most things in the
world, you build a brand.
A bottled water is not proprietary.
Like, they say it is, but it's not.
Most things are not proprietary.
- [Crystal] Okay.
- A sneaker's not.
You know, the innovation
in sneakers has evolved,
but a t-shirt, let's go there.
T-shirts aren't proprietary.
But for awhile there,
Abercrombie and Fitch,
for awhile there,
American Apparel for awhile there,
for now Supreme.
When you don't have any proprietary value,
you have to build a brand.
- [Crystal] Okay, and how
do I start that for them?
- You make content for the people
that are buying the product.
So, you're in the B to B
business, I assume, right?
- [Crystal] Yes, both actually.
- B to B and B to C, right?
- [Crystal] Yes.
- So you make content for the B to B world
and you make content for the B to C world.
You make a funny video for Instagram
and target people that are most likely
to buy memory cards, or
employees of organizations.
Here's what I always do,
when you want to do it for a company.
I look at where the money's coming from
and I make content for those people,
meaning I would look at where
sales are being generated
and then I would make content
for that cycle and demographic.
So if you're biggest client is Staples,
I would make content
for the Staples buyer.
If you're selling a ton on Amazon,
I would look at the data and be, like,
why is everybody from
Wisconsin buying our product?
Let's make some Wisconsin based here.
I reverse-engineer the actual
people that are buying.
And try to figure out
how to bring them value
in utility or entertainment
in my creative,
which then leads to, you know, ROI.
I'm both utility and
escapism entertainment.
People watch DailyVee and my
clips both for information,
but a lot of people don't even realize,
a lot of people are watching
just for entertainment.
They just want to see what the trials
and tribulations of Babin
versus DRock are today.
(woman laughs)
- [Crystal] I saw that clip when you said
that you might get DRock to Babin.
- That's right, see?
- [Crystal] You'll get there Babin.
- See, Babin?
- [Babin] Appreciate that.
- This was a very meta
moment for me, right?
Like a lot of people,
I'm doing both, more
utility than entertainment.
But clearly both.
And I think, you watch
Star Wars for a reason
and you watch a how-to video
for a memory card for a reason.
And both work.
Those are the two pillars
that you trade on.
- [Crystal] Okay.
And just to add to that,
I find that my bosses,
they're kind of scared
that someone's gonna take our idea,
because it's not
proprietary, and run with it.
And as I've been watching you,
you really preach on what the people,
even if they know how to do it
they're not gonna do it the exact way.
- How many employees work in the company?
- [Crystal] I believe six.
It's not a lot of us.
- And do you understand
the proprietary nature
of what you guys do?
If you left tomorrow would you be able to,
if you had enough money, do it as well?
- [Crystal] Yes, actually.
- Then your bosses are not very smart.
And I'm saying that in a tough way.
And I don't really mean it,
but this is what makes me laugh at people.
The reason I'm a good guy
and giving everything away
is there are no secrets.
Why wouldn't it be scary for you
to go and work with a competitor?
They're old school in their thinking.
They haven't calibrated the
extreme nature of the internet.
Too many people are trying
to hold onto a secret that doesn't exist.
And so what that does is
it makes them religious
about defense when it's
never been more important
to go on the offense.
- [Crystal] Okay.
- But that's a tough play because,
I don't think you walking in to the room
is gonna convince them.
Do you know what I mean?
- [Crystal] Right, and
I don't think so either.
- But maybe they'll watch this full clip
whenever I put it up in full in a month,
and maybe that will get them going.
Because they're not sitting on anything.
- [Crystal] I'm famous now?
- Yes, this whole video's going out.
You're famous now.
- [Crystal] Yes!
(laughs)
- So, listen, that's just the way it is.
Most companies, when they hit
a level where they're happy
they try to go on defense when they think
they're sitting on a secret.
But they're not sitting
on as big of a secret
as they think.
- [Crystal] Okay, alright.
- The inter-media would
be smaller not bigger
if I held on to all of these good ideas.
- [Crystal] True, very true.
Very, very true.
- Alright, this was a lot of fun.
See what happens when
you ask on the internet?
Shit happens.
- [Crystal] Yes, oh my
god, I love you, Gary!
Thank you so much for taking the time.
I'm so, so grateful that you
took the time out of your day.
- No worries, take care, goodbye.
- [Crystal] Alright, bye.
- Keep on tweeting.
(heartfelt piano plays)